as children here in telford these women
were groomed abused and sold to men for
sex
i thought this was the norm
i didn't understand what was happening
because it was happening to the other
girls as well
for joanne it began when she was just
12.
by the time she was 16 her abuser had
forced her into prostitution there were
guns involved
lots of weapons were used on me
trapped afraid and alone they all felt
blamed by the authorities social
services let me down the police because
they would see us on the street and just
drive past
i was 15 when i gave birth to my son um
i gave birth alone
uh the stigma that was attached to that
even in the hospital that i gave birth
in i was one of the midwives
said to me who are the teddies for you
or the baby because i was getting
arrested by the police i was seen as a
criminal
so you start then thinking well i
deserve this
the report looked into claims that the
involvement of asian men in child abuse
led to fears within west mercier police
of being branded racist in echoes of
similar reports in places like rotherham
and rochdale it found there was a
reluctance among officers to police a
part of telford
the murder of 16 year old lucy lowe seen
here on the left her sister and their
mother scared children into silence
lucy's abuser azar ali mehmed set fire
to their home she'd given birth to his
baby when she was just 14.
her uncle says that should have alerted
the authorities instead like so many
others she was blamed for her abuse they
thought they were promiscuous all
bad they're not bad the bad people were
the ones doing this
child sex location within our town under
our noses
and
obviously somebody knew
the report concludes the authorities did
know and suffering and deaths of
children could have been avoided both
the council and police have apologized
we failed to protect people adequately
in the past and i want to be really
straightforward in
apologizing to those victims and
survivors and anyone who's had their
lives marked by
exploitation
survivors say change is urgently needed
to protect children now and in the
future becky johnson sky news telford